so today we want to talk about the most
accurate way to assess your blood
Sugar's okay
so we'll talk about a1c by checking your
blood glucose when you're fasting and
checking your blood glucose when you're
post-meal I'm not going to actually
mention the glucose tolerance test where
you're going to consume actual glucose
and then measure your blood sugars
simply because you're never going to
consume just pure glucose and your diet
okay so that's not going to really give
you an accurate assessment of what's
going on so let's start with a1c okay a
1c is not as accurate as blood glucose
simply because it's not measuring to
your blood glucose levels directly it's
giving you a rough estimate of your
blood sugars over three months what it's
really measuring is the percent of
hemoglobin that is bound to glucose now
hemoglobin is the protein that carries
oxygen in your blood so a1c is the
percentage of how much hemoglobin that's
connected to that sugar okay in your
blood
now there's other similar measurements
you have A1B A1A1 A1A2
that's not binding to glucose but the
a1c is so this is what they use to
assess that now let's talk about anemia
there's a couple different types one is
where you have low iron if you have the
type of anemia that is low iron you're
gonna have an abnormally high a1c giving
you a false reading with your blood
sugars so it's not going to really be as
accurate to actually indicate high blood
sugar issues now there's another type of
anemia called hemolytic where you're
actually having destruction of the red
blood cells in which case you're going
to have a very low A1C you can also have
an infection which control this off you
can also have a liver disease or a
kidney disease or even being pregnant
and it can throw off this number right
here so we want to just use this as a
guideline it's not a bad test but
realize it's not 100% all right now
let's just bring up the point what is
normal blood sugar well it should be in
the 80s roughly between 70 and 90
milligrams per deciliter but if you are
a diabetic you're most likely not going
to
this right here at least initially until
you're working on it for many many
months even sometimes years because if
you're a diabetic
especially you've been a diabetic for a
long time you have insulin resistance
and many times you've lost up to 50% of
your beta cells those are the cells that
actually make insulin so we're really
dealing with a dysfunctional pancreas
and it's gonna be really hard to bring
this down simply because you don't have
all the cells that make insulin and this
is gonna leave you with a slightly
elevated blood glucose level okay now if
you really work on this and you do in a
minute fasting over a period of time I
believe you can bring it down pretty
close to a normal level okay here's one
of the challenges that I see with
diabetics they're going to their doctor
and the doctor is assessing them and
there they might be improving but they
can't seem to get the blood sugar down
without a lot of medication okay not to
mention the recommendations that they're
giving the person is usually higher
carbohydrate low fat you know type foods
so they're never going to be able to get
them even close to normal especially if
their carbohydrates in their diet
are just too high so that's one thing
but usually diabetics have a lot of
complications they have high blood
pressure they have eye problems they
have nerve problems they have heart
problems they have cholesterol problems
and they have a fatty liver so they're
on a lot of different medications and
the real problem is the side effect from
those medications are sometimes worse
than the side effects from the high
sugar okay now if you are a diabetic and
you do the keto plan and you're doing in
a minute fasting and you're doing great
but you can't seem to get this down to
where it needs to be and it's it's
higher just realize you can do certain
things to neutralize and minimize the
complications of that high sugar okay
and you can do it with high nutrient
dense foods okay that's why it's so
important when you do a healthy keto
plan
make sure those foods are high quality
having enough vitamin A vitamin C from
food b1 vitamin e vital okay those are
all antioxidants that are really really
important especially about mb1 if you
have enough b1 and get it from
nutritional yeast or a natural source
even if you have high sugar the
complications will be very minimal okay
so that's what you want to do if your
dad better kind of got diverted there a
little bit okay so let's go to the next
test fasting blood glucose level this is
not a bad test it'll give you some data
and of course normal would be like 80
okay really roughly between 70 and 90
but when it gets above 110 milligrams
per deciliter that's when you start to
have problems okay start do you have
damage to the cells of the pancreas or
call beta cells it's at 110 when you
start getting above 140 you start to
have more problems with the other
tissues like the heart especially the
inside of your arteries okay you start
getting inflammatory conditions the
kidney the nerves the fingertips and the
bottom of the feet and the brain okay so
so if you get your test back and it's
above 140 then we know what's happening
with this okay but again if you're a
diabetic okay and you're on keto and
you're doing really good it might be
really hard to even get it down here at
least initially but that's okay if you
keep eating really healthy you'll be
protected now the absolute best and most
accurate way to assess your blood
Sugar's is post meal okay one to two
hours this gives you the dynamics of how
your pancreas releases insulin to push
those blood sugars down normal after one
to two hours should be 120 or less and
then eventually at two hours it should
be below a hundred okay so anything
above that would be a problem so this
right here is rarely talked about it's
it's really assessed now if you have a
blood glucose meter I would highly
recommend
focusing on this assessment right here
and your method of knowing your blood
sugars are in check alright thanks for
watching
so if you've personally benefited from
the information that I put on my videos
I would love to actually see your
success story - I put a link down below
so you can upload your before and after
pictures with your story